following his foray back into stardom
this year starring in ryan reynolds
latest ad for mint mobile
canadian national treasure rick moranis
has been the victim of a random attack
in the streets of new york in the video
the perpetrator can be seen assaulting
rick
punching him in the head outside an
upper west side apartment building
early thursday morning and then walking
away rick hurt his head
back and hip in the attack but was able
to take himself to the hospital
and the police station to report the
incident with his name trending on
twitter
fans of the honey chunk the kids star
are outraged
sparking a social media wide search for
the man seen
in the video chris evans tweeted my
blood is boiling
find this man you don't touch rick
moranis while miranda's number one fan
ryan reynolds apologized for subjecting
the actor to
this year writing should have known not
to subject rick to the year
2020. glad to hear he's okay rick's rep
told et canada
rick moranis was assaulted on the upper
west side yesterday
he is fine but grateful for everyone's
thoughts and well wishes
you